nouveau volet de notre série
la bourgogne comme ils l'aiment des
comédiens comédiennes attaché à la
région leur terre d'origine ou
d'adoption nous font partager leur
attachement à une ville de la région
rencontre aujourd'hui avec jacques
frantz canneberges et et isabelle
rivière ont suivi sur les traces de son
enfance dijonnaise
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
souvenirs
la marde fontaine-lès-dijon à chaque
fois que jacques france revient dans sa
ville natale
il y fait une halte
c'est là que je vais faire de la luge
quand j'étais petit legging frère
jean-philippe et on nous racontait des
tas de trucs ici saint bernard qui était
supposée être né dans le château qui sur
le plateau aurait un jour vu la mare
s'ouvrir et aurait entrevue les croiser
la deuxième ou troisième croisade je ne
sais plus qui se serait dépêché d'aller
prêcher à vevey
donc on se prenait tous un peu pour des
des très grandes personnes quand on
était petit et qu'on est elle à cheval
sur nos luges enfin c'était très
mystérieux très mélangées comme ça mais
c'est beau non
oui la tour entre les arbres
de l'émotion et des souvenirs aussi à
chacune de ses promenades dans le centre
ville de dijon
le comédien a hérité de son père
conservateur des monuments historiques
une vraie passion pour le patrimoine
architectural de la capitale
bourguignonne
en raison de ces maisons magnifiques et
je passais la devant quatre fois par
jour en rentrant de l'école
[Musique]
les six sculptures la ti personnages on
le voit et tout
pour le bar
le palais d etat incontournable c'est là
que jacques frantz se fait enfin ses
premiers pas sur scène à l'occasion du
festival des nuits de bourgogne
alors ici ont été les costumes on se
cachait ont changé d ont changé à toute
vitesse de costumes parce qu on fait
plein de trucs et les loges des acteurs
étaient dans les cuisines ducales ici
qui sont un endroit absolument sublime
voûtée de jce 14e siècle enfin commune
appelant bourgogne et avait un petit
escalier qui descend des il fallait pas
faire de bruit pas c'était magique quoi
c'est une boîte magique
une magie qui opère été après été
jusqu'à ce que jacques frantz eux
s'inscrivent logiquement dès 16 ans au
conservatoire au grand théâtre cet
après-midi-là retrouvailles improvisé
pour le comédien avec son professeur
d'art dramatique de l'époque andré
comment va-t-il bien d'être une chaîne à
roybon c'est comme si vous demandiez
fait ressentir et roméo on retrouve en
juliette trois siècles après quoi c'est
de l'ordre de l'indicible ces panels de
choses déjà y est le lieu qui sublime la
présence d'andré qui pour moi est un
jalon et puis il ya eu ma vie et mon
enfance il ya mais c'est moi mes amours
mes rêves tous à dijon ces essais c'est
tout à
patchwork de trucs mais ça c'est un gros
morceau
[Musique]